five o'clock in the morning PC David
Carrick dragged from his bed and
arrested police officers right David do
you want me to come make it like this no
just understand you're under arrest okay
just explain to us what do you need like
this can one of my colleagues go and get
you stuff yeah more than a year later
Carrick admitted 49 sex crimes against
12 women okay
look
Carrick arrived at court to be sentenced
an obvious Target for those who campaign
against male violence
behind a public appearance of propriety
and trustworthiness
you took monstrous advantage of women
drawn into intimate relationships with
you
carrick's fate was broadcast live he was
damned by the judge's words the malign
influence of men like you in positions
of power stands in the way of a
revolution of women's dignity
we behaved as if you were untouchable
you are bold and at times Relentless
trusting that no victim would overcome
her shame and fear to report you
some victims did report Carrick but no
action was taken against him he kept his
job while he was harassing assaulting
and raping women
there was another apology from carrick's
old boss there are systemic failings in
this case we had opportunities where
where
warning signs were seen by the Met
reports allegations
and we didn't follow through on those
and that's why he was still a police
officer when he shouldn't have been
Carrick was jailed for Life a minimum 30
years before any chance of parole
several of the women Carrick attacked
were in court to see him jailed police
and prosecutors praised The Bravery of
carrick's victims but they believe there
are more they urged them to come forward
some already have
Carrick left to begin his sentence ahead
of him said the judge a difficult time
in custody for many years
in brunt Sky News at southwark Crown
Court